there were nine mass shootings over the
weekend in the u.s
according to the gun violence archive
the worst left
six dead at a family birthday party in
colorado springs
in new york's times square a
four-year-old child was caught in
crossfire
as that city deals with the
proliferation of weapons we have been
taking guns off the street in new york
city
at an alarming rate over the last two
years and it's time now that we have
consequences for those
2020 was a year dominated by the deadly
covert 19 pandemic but despite
lockdowns and less outdoor activity
major cities saw spikes
in murder rates places like los angeles
chicago and new york all recorded surges
of at least
30 percent experts say covert anxiety
loss of jobs and fewer police on the
streets are all factors
you now have a pent-up populace
that is combining with guns mental
health
and everything that all of us went
through last year and you're opening
back
up the demand for firearms last year led
to 3 million more guns being sold than
normal
according to the brookings institute
many of those sales were driven by
concerns
over personal safety and the civil
unrest following the death of george
floyd at the hands of police
i fear that we're going to see these
things happen
uh continually but i what i don't want
is i don't want people to be
desensitized to this normalcy we
shouldn't accept this as part of our
normal no other country in the world
does
as this nation begins its slow recovery
from the pandemic
the scars from a period that's hit the
disadvantaged hardest
may continue during the pandemic overall
crime fell but it's a dramatic rise
in shootings and murder that has many
concerned
it's hoped the vaccine roll out schools
reopening and increased
employment will help statistics at this
stage aren't necessarily an indicator of
future trends
but it's clear the defeat of covid19 may
be the best solution
for now andy gallacher al jazeera miami
florida